in europe denmark is way ahead of the
u.s in terms of dropping restrictions
and generally acting as if the pandemic
is over chris livesay is in copenhagen
with how that's possible chris good
morning good morning michelle yeah covet
cases are soaring in denmark now in the
past that's often meant shutting down
the entire country this time the
government is taking a radically
different approach in the opposite
direction to the envy of some but to the
horror of others
[Music]
imagine a long time ago in a galaxy far
far away
where the term super spreader event has
no meaning welcome to denmark
the land that's dropped all of its
coveted restrictions
social distancing so long face masks
forget about it but if you thought covet
had disappeared think again the
scandinavian nation has one of the
highest levels of the omicron variant in
europe but that's not stopping prime
minister mehta frederickson if you ask
me for just one answer why and how are
denmark able to lift up restrictions it
is because of the vaccines
more than 80 percent of the population
is fully vaccinated and nearly 100
percent of the elderly are boosted
voluntarily with no need for mandates i
am not afraid are you vaccinated yes
three times
danes endured two years of tough
lockdowns and while now many are still
catching kovid they're not overwhelming
icu's at least not for now the world
health organization was aghast by
denmark's bold reopening and warned it
could backfire so now is not the time
to lift everything all at once so what
makes
you so certain that the who is wrong and
that denmark is right they are not wrong
they can be right and we can be right at
the same time so if you get the same
vaccine rate then maybe you can do as
what what we have done in denmark so
you wouldn't recommend doing this in the
united states
certainly not
at the moment there are only about 30
patients in denmark's icus if those
numbers shoot up the government says
it'll reconsider restrictions and
possibly even a fourth dose of vaccine
for now denmark is enjoying life
coming back to normal
as it waits for the rest of the world
to catch up
now other countries are following suit
like nearby sweden and norway has
recently dropped most of its
restrictions as well of course people
are still catching kovid here in fact
one of the latest people to test
positive none other than the queen of
denmark herself she's 82 years old so
far only has mild symptoms tony
glad to hear it christopher livesay from
a galaxy far far away aka copenhagen
hope we can visit soon thank you very
much